عام غير حياه الاوكرانيين والعالم معه ها
هي العاصمه كيف تستيقظ اليوم على وقع عام
من الحرب هنا في ميدان الاستقلال في كييف
الالم سيد المشهد الاوكرانيون يتطلعون الى
ايام ومستقبل افضل
هناك حياه قبل وبعد هذا اليوم غادرت منزل
منذ عام ولم ارى عائله منذ ذلك الوقت
الامر مؤلم بالنسبه الي يشعر بالم لا يوصف
ولا اريد تذكر كل ما عانيته
اشعر بقلق شديد منذ الصباح لكنني مازلت
واتمنى اياما افضل بكيت قليلا اليوم ما
يحدث صعب جدا ومؤلم لكنني مقتنعه ان كل
شيء سيكون على ما يرام في اوكرانيا
في كلمه القاها بمناسبه مرور عام على بدء
الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا صرح الرئيس هوليود
مرزيلنسكي ان بلاده ستفعل كل شيء لتحقيق
النصر هذه السنه
العالم مشاهد على ما تستطيع اوكرانيا
القيام به جنودنا هم الابطال الجدد
المدافعون عن
ازوفستال مكاسب جديده لقواتنا في خار كيف
وغيرها مدن بطوليه عواصم لن تهزم اخترت
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
ديمتريديف من جهتي اكد ان روسيا ستنتصر في
اوكرانيا ومستعده للوصول الى حدود بولندا
من المهم تحقيق جميع اهداف العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه علينا دفع حدود التهديدات
لبلادنا الى ابعد ما يمكن حتى لو كان ذلك
عند حدود بولندا علينا تدمير النازيين
في الاثناء يتواصل القتال بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه مع زياده الغموض بشان
تطورات الحرب
وسيناريوهات توقفها